Penn State crackdown on Greek
organizations after the death of
sophomore Timothy Piazza he died after a
drunken fall following an alleged hazing
ritual involving forced drinking a teen
Beta Theta Pi brothers faced criminal
charges after allegedly leaving Piazza
injured on the floor for more than 12
hours before calling 911 State
University band the chapter
this year alone schools including Loyola
University the University of Central
Florida and the universe and the
University of Arizona have suspended
fraternities after hazing allegations
jetson Horace's president and CEO of the
north american interpreter nity
conference this organization represents
69 minutes fraternities including Beta
Theta Pi he is here for his first TV
interview since a Penn State incident
good to have you at the table John let's
start with the Penn State incident
because that for most people was so
egregious shocking and made people very
angry as you know we spoke with the
Piazza family and the father said Jim
Piazza said listen this isn't boys being
boys this was a murder of our son as
Nora mentioned there's Timothy was left
laying there for 12 hours before people
got help what responsibility do you
think your organization holds for the
death of this boy well there's no doubt
it went from a fraternity situation of
binge drinking and hazing into after the
fall a completely unacceptable
reflection on humanity those students
should be held fully accountable we
fully support that process and it's also
driving a reflection period for all
fraternities and frankly all campuses in
higher education I've been called
countless times since this talking about
the issue of binge drinking and hazing
but specific to what happened those 12
hours after there is no reason there is
no excuse there's going to have to be a
lot of reflection around how do we
balance amnesty and how do we balance
firm expectations and making sure
students feel safe to call for help but
at the same time having expectations
that it's unacceptable be fully
accountable mean the possibility of
criminal charges
we encourage criminal charges down
granted they need to go through their
process but we think the state laws on
hazing need to and should be enforced
fully to combat hazing it won't fix it
all there's many other opportunities
ways to get at this problem but we
encourage that level of accountability
in our system Penn State told us that
across the country fraternity chapters
alumni boards and national fraternity
organizations through the
self-governance model have failed to
bring an end to excessive drinking
hazing sexual assault you represent
these fraternities why is there still
this level of drinking allowed in
fraternities here's the reality of what
we face on college campuses
you have the drinking law and then you
have the reality of the students and we
are caught in a very challenging
position to ensure safety have honest
dialogue about where they are enforce
policies but when it comes down to it
what works best and where we find
success is when administrations and
national organizations from the grass
stops work with the student culture
which is at the grassroots you
acknowledge it's not working yeah I
acknowledge that there's issues on
campus and in certain fraternities and
those issues need to be directly but
there have been a 60 deaths over eight
years involving fraternity activities
there should be zero tolerance this
there should be immediate action on this
it is unacceptable this is murder
exactly we have banned it over and over
again the challenge we've got is 1,800
students on college campuses died from
alcohol poisoning last year this is
bigger than just fraternities now we
have to take responsibility we have to
lead the culture change on campuses I'm
we are a hundred percent behind that but
the system that we're operating in is
challenging as well so again where we
make progress is when the students
engage in as you know there's a growing
call for the end of fraternities on
college campuses because of just the
kinds of things that Nora was talking
about we need to ban the behavior and
ban those students that get involved in
that including the chapters let me read
you this most of the individuals or
their attorneys have not yet committed
on the allegation but one attorney said
the state is placing quote an impossible
burden on the young men and assuming
they could tell the difference between
difference between extreme intoxication
and a life-threatening injury what do
you say to that
look there are thousands of fraternity
men who see people injured and make a
phone call in those moments I respond
with their I don't know the specific
there but when someone is injured this
is not about fraternity this is about
humanity so my response is let the
criminal process play out for that in
the meantime we need to work with
students to set firm expectations this
behavior has been banned work with them
to create the culture change at the
grassroots level so the top of the
administration and their policy and
expectation that students don't seem to
be able to police themselves of jud here
that's the that's the issue they're not
policing themselves there is no doubt
that we have issues with accountability
and self-governance but there are
thousands of examples where they do
where they do step in where they do
Governor Kasich who was just talking
about the role of parents the role of
making good decisions the most important
governing so much for coming before we
got a bet were up against our clock in
chair it is